Disney's lawsuit was filed just minutes
after a board appointed by Governor Ron
DeSantis nullified Provisions that
allowed the company to largely govern
the land around Disney World in its suit
Disney calls the board's decision
patently retaliatory patently
anti-business and patently
unconstitutional DeSantis has called
Disney's opposition to the law out of
line they're upset because they're
actually having to live by the same
rules as everybody else they don't want
to have to pay the same taxes as
everybody else and they want to be able
to control things without proper
oversight the feud goes back to March of
last year when Disney spoke out against
the state's parental rights and
education law
which bans lessons relating to sexual
orientation and gender identity in
Florida classrooms previously only
applied to grades k-3 was expanded in
recent weeks through the 12th grade